depuis le 1er juillet dernier c'est une
réalité
la tva dans la restauration à baisser
les prix aussi normalement enfin ça ne
se voit pas toujours au moment de passer
à la caisse
à mon avis il n'ya que les restaurateurs
qui en profitent quand il ya des plats
indique avec une baisse de tva je
choisis effectivement les plats qui ont
la baisse de tva
forcément au fait il baisse la tva sur
les produits qui se vendent le mois en
fait genre choux de bruxelles côtes de
porc c'est pas le truc qui se vend
beaucoup sur le reste menu entrée plat
dessert ou café
les 180 milles restaurateurs français se
sont engagés à baisser leurs prix sur au
moins sept produits a augmenté les
salaires de leurs employés et embaucher
à tour de bras mais trois mois après
l'entrée en vigueur de cette mesure quel
est le bilan
y at il des petits malins qui gruge le
consommateur l'état s'est-il fait rouler
dans la farine en baissant la tva
combien ça coûte l'hebdo décortique
l'addition par le menu
la petite ville balnéaire de moutiers en
retz au sud de la vendée dans ce
restaurant de plage la baisse de la tva
connais pas on ne peut pas se tromper
c'est écrit en gros sur l'uniforme du
personnel ces prix ont baissé pas les
frites annoncé moins bien c'est pascal
le patron qui a eu l'idée d'imprimer ses
tee-shirts
au départ c'est pour être peinard en
pleine saison se tient tous les gens
vont nous agresser à la tva vous baissez
pas les prix comme ça on l'affiché
directement comme ça on est tranquille
lisons la sourire en plus des serveurs
du patron c'est bien à la taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée est passée de 19,6 % à 5
ennemis depuis le mois de juillet mais
le patron ne l'a pas répercuté sur ses
prix alors à la caisse pour les clients
ça ne change rien l'addition dommage
pour ce monsieur ça aurait pu faire 9
euros deux mois quand la douloureuse a
du mal à passer
parce qu'elle a un truc qui marche à
tous les coups il offre le digestif
entre arranger le consommateur ou se
refaire une trésorerie
parce qu'elle a choisi ça nous fait
économiser 50 mille euros de tva sur
l'année ac oui c'est énorme on pourra
faire ce qu'on veut de cet argent là
bien sûr après on peut s'acheter à 4 4
si on veut c'est pas interdit harakat à
comment dire à 40000 euros cinquante
mille euros chacun on ne l'interdît pas
un an d'hésitation il m'a prévenu
finalement parce qu'elle n'a pas acheté
de 4,4 pour savoir ce qu'il a fait d'une
partie de son argent
il n'ya qu'à lire les fameux tee-shirt
là vous avez là répond que des piles sa
revendication si on baisse pas les prix
côté face la réponse oui ils
augmentaient salaires voilà voilà
les cinq employés ont en effet été
augmenté et pas une petite augmentation
aujourd'hui justement ces jours de paix
allons assurer 1 2644 romane où est
passé à 1844 euros nets
ça fait 200 euros de plus de quoi
s'offrir son abonnement à la salle de
gym par exemple cette augmentation va me
permettre de faire ça et faire des à
côtés puis bon vin comme dit toto un peu
plus de plus des restos avec avec les
enfants puis une autre femme quand voilà
que du plaisir
la politique du patron a payé son
chiffre d'affaires a augmenté
mécaniquement de 10% sans rien faire
contrairement à pascal un restaurant sur
deux aurait répercuté la baisse de la
tva
pourtant les consommateurs ont le
sentiment que les prix n'ont pas
vraiment baissé
pour en avoir le coeur net nous avons
subi aude sur les champs elysées en
choisissant des établissements au hasard
aude tient un blog de critiques
gastronomiques sur internet
premier constat tous les restaurateurs
sont loin d'être transparent sur les
prix
théoriquement le restaurateur est
supposé barré en surprit pour qu'on voit
en fait la différence
et là on fait ça uniquement le nouveau
prix donc on peut pas bien se rendre
compte de la différence
ce n'est qu'un début en caméra cachée
nous entrons dans un premier restaurant
de la cuisine typiquement française ici
sept produits ont bien bénéficié de la
baisse de la tva
rien à redire mais quand nous cherchons
à savoir comment les plats ondes et des
sélectionnés surprise
en fait c'est parce que je voulais en
fait
boilard choisi les produits n'a pas
d'obligation qui rendent le plus sur une
année
s'il est réparé
il doit évacuer la fois
dans des cas comme ça
moralité comme étant d'intérêt
c'est le moyen que certains
restaurateurs on trouvait pour limiter
la perte sur leur chiffre d'affaires
dans cet autre restaurant de spécialités
japonaises
ils font encore plus fort les prix ont
effectivement baissé mais les quantités
dans l'assiette aussi
et si c'était tranquille a baissé aussi
sanchez
décidément il faut toujours y regarder à
deux fois
n'y a pas de contrôle y a pas de
législation très clair donc en fait les
restaurateurs ont tout loisir va de
pouvoir adapter à leur sauce en fait
c'est la terrière pourtant aider les
restaurateurs ça coûte très cher à
l'état 2 milliards et demi d'euros en
moins dans ses cages chaque année alors
pour dessiner l'autocollant officiel
c'est carrément le secrétaire d'état qui
s'y est collé c'est moi qui les fais
c'est moi qui ai conçu comme ça ça c'est
moins cher
il n'y a pas de petites économies
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est est de
relancer la consommation et de créer des
emplois
trois mois après les engagements sont
loin d'être tenues
mais le secrétaire d'état ne perd pas
espoir vous verrez quand on fera les
comptes
eh bien on verra que cette mesure qui
coûte aujourd'hui de l'argent au fisc en
rapportera aussi y compris aux
consommateurs en rythme annuel
aujourd'hui il ya 50 millions d'euros
qui ont été rendus de au mois d'août 50
millions d'euros qui ont été rendus au
mois de septembre aux consommateurs
français sur la basse sur la baisse des
prix de certains produits
du côté de l'opposition didier migaud
lui aussi a fait les comptes
et pour ce député cette baisse de la tva
c'est un cadeau de deux milliards et
demi fait aux restaurateurs
et ce alors même que l'état est
surendetté nous dit va coûter en baisse
la tva
et puis si les engagements sont pas
respectées ça fait rien voilà il ya deux
milliards et demi comme ça qu'ils sont
d'une certaine façon décidée en
réduction d'impôt par par l'état et qui
sont seulement financé à crédit
donc quand vous financer à crédit bon
c'est toujours le même problème
vous reportez le moment de la facture
mais pas le montant de la facture qui
n'ira pas vous arriver si cette baisse
coûte cher à l'état et aux contribuables
elle devait en contrepartie créer des
emplois les restaurateurs s'étaient
engagés à créer 40 milles en deux ans
le problème et il suffit d'aller faire
un tour à l'anpe du coin pour s'en
rendre compte c'est que la profession a
déjà beaucoup de mal à recruter
il y aurait aujourd'hui soixante mille
offres d'emploi qui ne trouveraient pas
preneur horaires à rallonge mal payés le
métier ne ferait pas rêver d'un mois la
petite fourchette 1400 à 1600 euros pour
une expérience voilà deux ans à deux ans
et à ce prix là le serveur doit parler
anglais et baragouiner l'espagnol et le
japonais
les entreprises ont du mal à recruter
sur ces postulats en service en cuisine
factuellement rien banques avec la
baisse de la tva ils vont pouvoir créer
40000 emplois de plus dans la
restauration ça vous dit quoi eh ben je
dirais que ça voilà c'est un bel
objectif maintenant voilà on verra dans
les mois qui viennent c'est
effectivement ça peut fonctionner ce
conseiller sceptiques et n'est pas le
seul même philippe séguin l'homme qui
est chargé de veiller à la bonne
utilisation de l'argent public doute de
l'effet baisse de tva
selon ses calculs 6000 emplois devraient
être créés au maximum alors qui sont les
grands gagnants de cette baisse de la
tva
les grandes chaînes de restauration bien
sûr comme elles font de gros volumes
elles peuvent se permettre de pratiquer
des prix très attractifs alors la baisse
de la tva s'affiche partout et en gros
-13% sur le menu du midi - 2 euros 50
sur la côte de boeuf
les résultats ont été immédiats marche
très très bien puisqu'on a gagné 40 % de
ventes sur les menus connaissent presse
ainsi que sur les côtes de boeuf
alors aujourd'hui on a une fréquentation
qui est supérieure à celle qu'on avait
avant la baisse de la tva
l'année dernière les clients boudent et
la troisième chaîne de restauration
française
aujourd'hui la tendance est inversée
cette mesure devrait rapporter 27
millions d'euros de plus par an groupe
et il prévoit même d'ouvrir 22 nouveaux
restaurants merci qui merci la baisse de
la tva